[Music]
[Music]
well i i've been an
economist since i was a second year
student at eu university
and i love economics admire it
but
it's narrow
and it's unnecessarily so i'm adam smith
i always cross myself when i mention
adam smith because he's my hero was a
broadly
educated person he was a philosopher
first
and an economist the word didn't even
exist
after being a philosopher
and i think that the right way to
understand the economy
is to
in a sort of smarter like phrase that i
sometimes use
leave the
the humans in it and
what that means in sort of practical
scientific terms
is not that you throw away the
mathematics or or the numbers or or
anything or the experiments for that
matter but that you add
the humanities
or arts um
objects as you say in britain
so you add you so so an economist should
be
uh
aware of philosophy in a serious way
and aware of history for sure
but also novels
poetry
uh
other ways
of seeing into how people
understand
the economy in fact
in a short phrase
i want to bring meaning back
into the study of economics
as opposed to
looking down at the economy as though we
were all a bunch of rats
and you can't get inside their minds
because you're not allowed to
because of some stupid
uh understanding
in fact i
just published a book
on this a very short book that which is
unusual for
me these days
which was just
reviewed very favorably
in the ft so i hope all your
all your all the auditors will rush down
and order the book
[Music]
well
this is the problem in behavioral
economics
which i i regard
with
something approaching
deep annoyance
um
sure you're irrational i'm irrational
there's no question about it come on i i
you you should see my my closet
then you would know that this is an
irrational person
but that doesn't mean that the market or
the or the the economic system as a
whole which i don't call capitalism
i call innovism i think that's a much
better word more accurate word
um is is going to make gross mistakes
in in his let's consider it
this way
um
if
you're irrational in your consumption
there will arise in opportunity and it's
not it's not by magic it's just by
ordinary
common sense thinking
for some firm
to help you be
more rational
for example the famous oxford street
department stores names escaping me
was founded by an american who had
learned his trade
in chicago in the um
in the in marshall fields department
store
and the idea there was to provide high
quality goods
uh and a guarantee
if you didn't like the goods you you
could get a full um
refund
and
then you don't need to be as rational
so
that's what i find is very uh disturbing
is from a scientific point of view about
behavioral economics from the outside of
economics
people love behavioral economics because
say well i'm i'm stupid surely in
economics that assumes that everyone's
stupid must be a better economics but
the system as a whole
is not stupid necessarily it might be
it might be that these
these stupidities of ours
have awful economic consequences but
that remains to be seen and it's seldom
if ever asked in behavioral economics
[Music]
well i think there are
two ideas and they're in conflict all
the time
there's the idea
that you know i should be able to buy
what i want and if i want to fill my
closet with clothes that i don't ever
wear
that should be my right so that's one
one side of it and indeed
people express themselves through their
consumption they go on
fancy holidays to antarctica or or
something
and that's an expression of their bird
watching obsession
that's fine
so that's one side the other side
is that we've got to get organized
and that comes from a very strong
analogy that people have in their head
that a nation is like a family
and we all come from families
and
mom was the was the central planner
and of course in our own lives
individual lives and in our family life
we try to be sensible
and we try to plan
so it must be so as a as a cousin of
mine said when i was talking to her
about it
a complicated modern economy
needs more regulation
more planning
if someone in in in whitehall or or
washington
is planning stuff for you
i'm from the government and i'm here to
help you
uh
that's not consistent
with my non-slave
self as a free person
[Music]
well
in a plague
the government certainly has a role and
as a 19th century
liberal i'm in favor of quarantine and
all that sort of stuff
i think it's been clumsily handled both
in britain and in the especially in the
united states with the trump and his his
lunatics
but but it it um yes and indeed one one
thing the governments
should have a role
of a similar character is invasion
if
napoleon
is going to invade britain
or if the canadian so i can't sleep at
night with worry about the canadians
invading the united states then we
should have an army and
the government has a role in
in
in doing that so
what should have happened and oddly
didn't happen
is
an initial lockdown swinging
lockdown
really keep people at home for
even as much as a month
and then
miraculously we've developed these
vaccines
and so then you immediately make the
vaccines available
and that didn't happen very strangely in
australia for example
only about i think the figure is now
about two percent of the population is
vaccinated
well that's really stupid that's bonkers
they closed down they didn't have a big
problem with uh kovid people are going
to the beach and everything at
bondi and so forth
and that's fine
but then it's what they should have done
the government should have is then
rushed and gotten as much of the vaccine
as they could and make sure that
everyone gets vaccinated then they could
open the australian economy i mean open
it to foreign people but they didn't do
it and they didn't do it in new zealand
they didn't do it in taiwan
this is very
bad policy
so yes
the government has a role in a plague
but it's got to be done intelligently or
it's not going to make us any any better
off
[Music]
well
i think the word
libertarianism
really got to be
got to be thrown away it it was
defined this way
in the 1950s
it's a problem because people don't know
what it means now the problem is that
the word liberal
for for about a century has been
especially in my country has been
drifting away
from its original meaning
although actually it started to drift
with the so-called new liberals
in britain in the 1870s
and 80s
um
liberalism doesn't mean state control of
everybody
but that's what it's come to mean in in
the
united states a sort of a
sloppy version of social democracy is
what people
mean in the united states when they say
i'm a liberal
well i want to take they they my
my friends who are of this character
are sort of worried about the word
because the the conservatives have made
made trouble for them so now they call
themselves progressives
and that gives us a chance we real
liberals to seize back the word
in the sense of mary
wollstonecraft or henry david thoreau or
john stuart mill or milton friedman
milton friedman indeed
[Music]
yeah that's crucial
because
the usual way we think about politics is
so
so simple-minded it's very distressing
we have the left-right
spectrum
and everyone's supposed to sign up for
their place on the spectrum they're
fascists or their communists or their
conservatives or their their socialists
or their
uh
left middle or right middle and we're
all lined up there
but
the argument that's going on along the
spectrum
is merely
how to use
the massive powers of the state
to boss people around
on the right
the massive powers of the state are to
be uh
used to make the make the army bigger
and to invade other countries
and to
suppress the
working class that's what the army's for
and that that you have to have a big
government that
spends a lot on armies and tanks on the
one hand and on the left
not to go all the way to
communism
it means intervening massively and and
telling people
the
united states federal government
has over one
million
regulations
and i imagine i i know the same is true
in britain
and this is
bonkers this is insane we don't need
that many instructions from from from
the central government so we liberals
real liberals
we don't think that's a good thing to
happen we don't like these big
governments we we agree there's a role
for the government
but it's not
big
look
in 1900
even in very advanced countries
the share of government expenditure
national income at all levels of the
government
was around 10 percent
now in britain it's about about 40
percent
in france it's 55 percent
uh in the united states and japan it's
about 35
well this this is
this is a government that's massively
too big
now if the government were helping poor
people with this cash
that it's extracted from you and me are
these resources that it's extracted from
you and me i would not be
as alarmed as i am
by the actual fact the government's
money is used to build up the army
it's used to
subsidize the regulations to subsidize
this or that
part of the population in
hurting the other part
it's used to build uh um
hs2
well
is hs2 a wonderful idea
there's a proposal to build a tunnel
between scotland and northern ireland
and the politicians love this kind of
stuff
they get to cut the
the ribbons and talk about the glorious
unification of britain
i wish they wouldn't and we that's the
attitude of we 19th century
uh liberals
and it's not cruel
i'm a christian
liberal
i i'm an anglican actually i acknowledge
uh a
responsibility towards the poor
if i actually tithe
to my church
i give ten percent of my income to my
church and they turn around and spend
most of it on poor people
so you know i
that that's i'm not being uncharitable
but the big charity that you can give to
poor people
is to
let them participate in the economy
and and
that is
prevented by a big modern state very
often
[Music]
well
think about the word capitalism it was
invented actually by the enemies of the
19th century
liberals
um oh that's not a
that's not anywhere near a decisive
argument
but it focuses on capital accumulation
as the way that we get better off
and up really until the late
1950s and gradually over the decades
after that
most economists believed that adam smith
the blessed adam smith across myself
believed that
the highlands of scotland if they would
just behave themselves
could become as rich as the dutch which
was his model of
a
high-income society
if they would just save and accumulate
and that's all you needed
and this was
this was translated into marxism for
example
and then in in conventional bourgeois
economics
of as i say up until
uh
50 years ago 70 or yeah about 50 years
ago economists believed this
and it was the the doctrine for example
at the world bank
that the way to make ghana rich
is to
put lots of
foreign aid into ghana and not one cent
into red china for example
and then ghana would be prosperous
and red china would stay poor
well you may have noticed that that
didn't happen
so
sheer capital accumulation without
innovation
without new ideas coming from the minds
of free
people from non-slaves
is just
piling up if you own an auto
how would you be a lot better off if you
had six autos
of course not
um if you have an apartment would it be
nice to have 12 apartments no
sheer capital accumulation doesn't
pay off it to express it as john maynard
keynes did in 1936
the marginal efficiency of investment
could be driven down to zero
in a generation which is to say
that sheer
piling up
of what we all agree are good things
like factories and roads and schools and
so forth
sheer piling up
doesn't do the trick that's not what
made us rich and boy did we become rich
from innovation
three
thousand percent better off than in
eighteen hundred now this this is people
find this number hard to believe but
it's
ask any economic historian and they'll
say yep that's about it
three thousand percent better off not
a hundred percent or two hundred percent
but three thousand percent
and that came from innovation
so what we'd better call this system we
have
is not capitalism
people are terminally confused about
this capitalism has always existed there
have always been middlemen and factories
there were factories for making uh
fish sauce and rum
there are factories to make
silk cloth in china from ancient times
no
it's innovation that was peculiar that
came after 1800.
[Music]
you